I've never experienced cult without
Debbie and I feel like I gained a son
now yeah
oh really really yeah
he needs to be taken care of he's very
high maintenance but you knew he was
locked up
well way back because you live with it
no no I I didn't realize how much you
did do for him and now that you know I'm
stuck with it I'm like holy she really
cannot take care of herself can you
she's like please move back into me yeah
well so interesting I like the last
hello I mean
Debbie was really blamed for the
majority of your problems now that
Debbie is not in the picture
still it has really shined the light I
just wanted to see the difference of if
Debbie was gone but now he's a child he
is 100 a child
all right so as Debbie was starting her
romance with Tony her relationship with
Colt was taking a turn for the worse
Colt had moved out and when he came to
pick up some of his things they found
themselves having one of their Infamous
fights take a look this is what you
totally don't understand
you think that because I am so connected
to you that I think you need me
have you ever thought that it was the
other way around and I need to chew
you're my son guilt trip you guilt-trip
me all the time what do you want I'm not
gonna watch no I just want no seriously
what do you want me as a mother what do
you want
whatever I don't care this is ridiculous
I can't I'm sorry I tried goodbye mom my
entire life has been your life you've
been the best driver of my life
what the hell is wrong with you
your dad would be so disappointed in you
know what Cole we're done
you treat me like a second-class citizen
you
out here
[Music]
let me ask Carl how does it feel sing
that again
I wish I could say I felt something but
I don't
I think she's kind of just Faking It
if you're going to talk to your mom have
a little bit more respect because you
only get one mom
[Music]